listen I'd like to tell you a story a  story of another person or age a young  girl she wanted to live a normal life  but she was chosen she was honored with  a special duty some people would call it  a sacrifice but what she didn't realize  at the time was that it was a great  honor while you've been drifting through  the universe eating ice cream playing  with trains war has been raging across  the galaxy  mog chothra will destroy this village  including your family what if we fought  the monster instead of feeding it you're  a dangerous girl Bella something tells  me we don't even know yet how much what  is this place please tell us where our  daughter is sick of being a prisoner on  this ship we have to save them shame are  you going  I found one of the crew are you me from  the future  you